et 1500 personnes bloqué derrière les
grilles qui ne parvenait pas à rentrer
qu'il a fallu aller délivrer ils ne sont
pas parvenus à entrer dans cette salle
parce qu'elle est pleine à craquer comme
vous pouvez en juger qui sort qui sont
donc dans le foyer qui nous regardent
sur un écran géant et je veux les saluer
pour leur guide compensable
et maintenant au nom de pau au nom du
béarn
au nom du pays basque au nom des
pyrénées atlantiques des landes des
hautes-pyrénées du gers de la gascogne
toute entière
de l'aquitaine anciennes et nouvelles et
de l'occitanie au nom du sud ouest tout
entier est en votre nom à tous
j'accueille et je salue emmanuel macron
[Applaudissements]
alors tous ici vous le savez nous sommes
des pères d'indépendance et de tolérance
nous sommes des terres animé d'esprit
civique
nous attachons du prix à la valeur
morale et à la valeur humaine et c'est
nous n'avons jamais oublier que nous
sommes la terre d'henri de navarre à qui
nous avons rendu visite cet après midi
mais aussi celle de montaigne et de
montesquieu
nous attachons du prix à la mémoire nous
savons d'où nous venons d'où viennent
nos cultures et nos langues
notre culture et notre langue française
nos langues et nos cultures régionales
qui sont aussi une part précieuse du
patrimoine national
et cette indépendance
cette tolérance cette valeur allez cette
valeur humaine ce sens de la culture
française de la culture européenne et de
la culture universelle
c'est cela que nous reconnaissons en
vous nous sommes rassemblés
parce que nous voulons que vous soyez
le prochain président de la république
française
[Applaudissements]
mais plus encore mais plus encore
nous sommes rassemblés parce que nous
croyons que vous serez le président de
la république du renouveau de la france
et du groupe
parce que tous ensemble nous formons un
pays et ce pays ne sont plus de n'avoir
aucun espoir
la france a été l' espoir de l'humanité
pendant des siècles et depuis des années
elle n'est même plus l'espoir
d'elle-même et c'est bien simple le pire
mal et le pire piège par la faute des
longues années détestable que nous avons
traversée les français ont perdu espoir
dans la france dans ses gouvernants dans
ses représentants dans ces institutions
dans ce qui devrait être des hommes
d'état et qui ne sont plus que des
politiciens car j'appelle politiciens
ceux qui pensent à leur parti pour
penser à leur pays
elle a perdu espoir dans ce qui devrait
l'appeler à la vérité est qu'ils mentent
sur l'essentiel dans ce qui devrait
donner l'exemple et qui s'autorisent au
contraire toutes les facilités tous les
laxisme tous les arrangements avec les
principes elle a perdu espoir dans ce
qui devrait montrer le chemin du courage
et montre le chemin de l'illusion dans
ce qui devrait rassembler le pays et qui
le divise c'est pour cela que nous
sommes ensemble un pays qui a failli se
noyer dans le pessimisme et qui
aujourd'hui un immense besoin
d'optimisme nous sommes
tous ensemble nous sommes je le dis en
votre nom à ce jeune président que nous
espérons nous sommes ce pays qui a
besoin d'y croire à nouveau
nous sommes ces femmes et ces hommes ces
étudiants ces travailleurs ces chômeurs
ces retraités qui voit poindre cet
espoir qui a pris cette année les traits
d'un jeune homme de picardie atypique
audacieux favorisée par la chance c'est
vrai mais qui a su la force et raison
pour laquelle nous sommes là et raison
pour laquelle je suis là moi qui ai
essayé d'ouvrir ce chemin conduisant des
millions de citoyens presque jusqu'à la
victoire et le presque entre 2007 et
ça fait toute la différence
je voudrais vous dire pourquoi je suis
heureux d'être là pour vous accueillir
et pour vous soutenir
et d'abord je voudrais dire un mot de
votre jeunesse
en fait vous ne vous n'êtes pas si
jeunes qu'on se plaît à le rappeler à
tout bout de champ à votre âge bonaparte
était au pouvoir depuis dix ans ils
étaient empereur depuis six ans
ea va t à votre âge alexandre le grand
avait depuis longtemps conquis le monde
et ils n'en étaient pas rentrer mais
vous serez un jeune président vous avez
à deux ou trois ans près l'âge auquel
john kennedy a été élu président des
états unis
exactement l'âge auquel matteo renzi
devenu chef du gouvernement italien et
justin trudeau premier ministre du
canada
par votre jeunesse vous serez sans doute
une exception en france mais vous ne
serez pas une exception dans le monde et
je vais vous dire ce que je crois
profondément
il est des moments dans l'histoire des
peuples où ils ont besoin de jeunesse
besoin d'écrire une page nouvelle sans
être embarrassée par l'immobilisme des
décennies passées
il est des moments où les peuples ont
besoin de cette respiration de cette
audace d'un regard nouveau sur le monde
ancien trop pollué par les laxisme les
dérives les compromissions
aujourd'hui la france a besoin de ce
regard nouveau de votre regard et de
votre jeunesse
car au travers de vous c'est la jeunesse
de la france la jeunesse qui est en la
france la jeunesse qui est dans tous les
âges de la france qui brûle de se faire
entendre et de s'exprimer car il ya en
france
d'immenses réserves de jeunesse
d'entousiasme d'énergie à tous les âges
voyez les associations les associations
qui font que le pays tient debout quand
on a l'impression que tout se défait
voyez les créateurs les les artistes et
les artisans et les créateurs donc voyez
les chercheurs dans tous les âges de la
france il y a cette générosité cette
envie de conquête qui se reconnaît
aujourd'hui dans le choix que vous lui
proposez vous avez une grande
responsabilité
il appartiendra au président que vous
serez de réconcilier la france avec elle
même non seulement les parties entre eux
les fractions en trail les camps entre
eux mais la france avec son destin
la france qu'on appelle éternelle
avec la france d'aujourd'hui et de
demain de rendre à la france confiance
en elle confiance dans ses forces
confiance face aux défis confiance en
ses institutions enfin et de rendre aux
français confiance en eux et entre eux
vous avez eu quelque chose qui est
absolument précieux vous avez de
l'audace vous avez compris très tôt que
ce système de pouvoir et de majorité
dont vous faisiez l'expérience camp
contre camp ne pouvait mener à rien
puisqu'il était impossible de les faire
travailler ensemble même quand il était
d'accord entre eux alors vous avez
quitté le gouvernement
et ça n'est pas facile de quitter le
gouvernement c'était un geste qui a
marqué et qui a ouvert cette aventure
vous avez compris très tôt que le destin
de la france n'était pas de milliers les
évolutions du monde mais de les assumer
et de s'armer pour y faire face et
commandent le comprendrions nous pas
hier vous étiez à besançon dans cette
région de france qui construit des
turbines des trains des automobiles pour
qu'ils exportations est la clef de la
survie et la force de l'avenir et
comment nous la firme ne rions nous pas
ici où sont fabriqués les moteurs les
plus performants de tous les
hélicoptères qui volent dans le monde
les ici où sont explorer les profondeurs
des sols de la planète
ici où sont dirigés les plateformes
offshore où est installée la seule usine
de fibre de carbone en europe et le
génie génétique et l'agroalimentaire ici
notre horizon quotidien c'est le monde
c'est la chine et la russie
c'est le moyen-orient ce sont les états
unis c'est l'inde et nous ne voulons pas
nous laisser enfermer
[Applaudissements]
vous avez eu l'audace et vous avez eu de
la voûte
vous avez affirmé et c'est très
important pour nous vous avez affirmé
que la haine la détestation des
adversaires la vocifération ce n'était
pas votre choix et que la bienveillance
elle même pouvait avoir droit de cité et
nous comprenons ce choix et nous le
soutenons
et vous avez montré aussi que quand on
vous cherche on vous trouve et que le
rugby ne vous est pas étranger vous qui
êtes un enfant en tout cas un petit fils
des pyrénées
vous avez eu de la force de conviction
vous qui avez voulu ne pas renier
l'idéal européen alors que tous les
autres lui tournait le dos et qui avait
montré et qui avait montré que ce n'est
pas l'idéal qu'il fallait renier mais la
manière dont on l'a fait dériver et la
volonté que nous avons avec vous et
autour de vous de le corriger
pour lui rendre sa puissance et
l'adhésion des peuples
voilà pourquoi contre toutes les
impasses contre ceux qui ont perdu
l'autorité morale qui permet seule de
gouverner les peuples contre ceux et
celles qui veulent faire flamber les
ressentiments et les rancoeurs contre
ceux qui prétendent en même temps
désarmé le pays et le frappe et d'un
choc fiscal d'une multiplication d'impôt
sans aucun précédent
voilà pourquoi vous êtes le candidat de
l'espoir des français
c'est une grande chance et c'est une
grande charge et au fur et à mesure que
les semaines ont passé nous avons vu
tous ceux qui sont vos plus proches
celle qui est votre plus proche nous
avons vu s'enraciner en vous la
conscience de cette responsabilité et
nous avons vu votre enthousiasme se
teinter de gravité voyez-vous pour moi
bien sûr j'attache du prix aux qualités
politiques être un leader convaincre
entraîné mais j'attache un prix encore
plus grand aux qualités humaines
j'attache du prix au caractère aux
femmes et aux hommes qui ne cède pas
qu'ils savent tenir leur cap et suivre
leur chemin
la tâche du prix à la générosité celle
qui permet de voir d'abord les êtres
humains et pas d'abord les galons qui
sont sur leurs épaules
j'attache du prix j'attache du prix à la
liberté d'esprit
celle qui permet d'échapper aux moules
et aux sentiers battus et en vous voyant
vivre d'assez près tous les jours depuis
des semaines et des mois
j'atteste que cette liberté de penser
cette générosité et ce caractère ce sont
les vôtres
j'attache un grand prix aux femmes et
aux hommes qui veulent tirer leurs
concitoyens et leur pays vers le haut et
non pas vers le bas les marécages des
insultes et des vociférations
on entendu ces derniers jours
l'affirmation que certains proposaient
qu'à défaut de les aimer il fallait
seulement les soutenir ici on ne siffle
pas vous souvenez de ça excusez moi et
mais ce n'est pas le bon verbe dans une
rencontre comme celle ci une rencontre
entre un homme et un peuple
nous nous croyons qu'il faut dès qu'il
faut que les dirigeants du pays soit
d'abord estimé et d'abord respecter
et pour cela il faut qu'il soit d'abord
estimable et respectable
avant d'être aimé henri iv a été
constamment estimé est constamment
respecté même par ses adversaires parce
qu'il n'a jamais accepté la division des
français et les réunir et les rassembler
c'est la meilleure et la plus belle
façon de les aimer c'est cet amour là
qui compte non pas l'amour qu'ont
revendiquerait de la part des peuples
mais l'amour que les hommes d'état
doivent porter à leurs concitoyens à
l'assemblée nationale vous le savez qui
est le haut lieu de la république il y a
beaucoup de statues beaucoup de bas
reliefs beaucoup de représentations de
révolutionnaire et de républicains et de
gouvernants mais il n'ya qu'une statut
de rois de france et c'est celle d'henri
iv qui domine la grande salle des
conférences et sur le piédestal de cette
statue du seul droit honoré par les
défenseurs de la république est gravé
cette phrase qui explique tout de cette
estime il est écrit la violente amour
que j'ai de mes sujets m'a toujours tout
rendu aisé et honorable vous est cher
emmanuel macron dans la capitale de la
réconciliation des français
pris racine l'édit de nantes qui permit
à la france durant presque un siècle
d'échapper à l'impôt et à l'intolérance
et aux guerres de religion je sais nous
savons tous que vous portez la même
promesse de réconciliation pour la
france d'aujourd'hui et de demain
et c'est au nom de cette promesse que je
vous dis pour aujourd'hui et pour demain
notre confiance et notre soutien nous
avons besoin de vous la france a besoin
de vous pour la rassembler et pour la
reconstruire
[Applaudissements]